Check me out. I'm a man.
I do what I want. I go where I want.
I have the right to vote.
I can legally own property.
-What are they so afraid of?
-Maybe they're scared
that if they teach us how the world works,
we'll figure out how to take over.
Oh my God, she's so insane.
Of course she's insane.
She's Emily Dickinson.
You're gonna make
a good housewife one day, Emily.
Oh, yeah. I'm a real catch.
You need to cut out these sort of antics.
Are you getting married?
I have one purpose...
and that is to become a great writer.
Because I could not stop for Death
He kindly stopped for me
Nice to see you.
Emily, I realized, without you,
I might as well not exist.
You really are
my favorite person in the world.
Read it when I'm gone.
You mean... when you're dead?
Dude, no, I mean,
like, when I'm in the other room.
Oh.
I do not approve of a woman
seeking to build herself
a literary reputation, Emily!
I am a poet.
And there is nothing you can do
to stop me.
You're gonna be a great poet...
the world will never forget.